If you are going to make renovations to your home,
quiet because they extend the tax deduction
up to 30 and 01/12/2024,
that you had not heard
because nobody gives it much hype,
right?
The tax deduction can be IR of between 5,000
up to €7,500 maximum,
both habitual and rented housing.
The objective
is to improve the energy efficiency of this home
and reduce consumption.
Recommendation
is to always ask for
the energy efficiency certificate
before making the reform.
I leave you the hacienda link
so you can take a look at it
and if you have any doubts,
let me know in the comments.
Follow me if
you want to find out everything that's going on on the bench